[Music]
horse meat sold at least a food scandals
with shook Europe in 2013 to prevent the
fraudulent deceptive practices any PS
will d sub sub safety controls now
clearly still beautiful none of that of
up to three Atticus cantilever
Hindenburg I was inoculated the appear
in la vieja minister of of hooks ticket
untied th assume that plants and assume
that the appellant of Shaffer Hooters
control in Gansa Hopa the new
legislation also aims to improve the
health and welfare as animals the goal
is to put an end to practices of animal
abuse during slaughter for instance the
feeling / vocal ability to be able to
claim this year's a result if I get
women here often theaters from the civil
eng get windows get Natalie of obesity
either complimenting on confirmation the
fact we have four other classrooms in
piazza by une of master flagstone
different wattages fears sanctum
stricter controls and a single framework
for all EU countries is the objective of
this new law performed forth from
farmer's land to consumers table through
cattle farming slaughter and
distribution all stages of the food
chain will be better control
you